after decades of trying to become a
Titan of Wall Street and build a global
investment bank deutsche bank is looking
to the home market the struggling lender
has announced a major restructuring plan
that would involve building on its
traditional strengths deutsche will
slash around a fifth of its staff
worldwide over three years it's scaling
back its investment banking operations
and will shift 74 billion euros of risky
assets into a new bad Bank as it's known
daughter also says it will cut some of
its fixed income operations an area
traditionally regarded as one of its
strengths younger plant we've been
planning for quite some time that after
achieving stabilization last year
cleaning up the balance sheet having
costs under control we now want to take
the next step matze to align the bank
with its strengths and that is what
we're pleased to have announced dosha
bank expects a 2.8 billion euro net loss
in the second quarter as a result of
restructuring charges and a loss for the
full year it's Frank first based
Deutsche Bank's deepest overhaul in
three decades and comes out of the
collapse of a planned merger with rival
Commerce Bank in that time the lender
tried and failed to keep up with Wall
Street's big guns like JPMorgan Chase
and Goldman Sachs now it's time for
Deutsche Bank to get its house in order
at home banking and finance professor
hans peter bull huff joins us from
stuttgart our financial correspondent
early Barths is in Frankfurt outside
Deutsche headquarters Olli is this
rocking Frankfurt it surely is it's
making its mark on the stock market
excuse me I have to fend off a pesky
wasp ear and the reaction is definitely
positive it's not euphoric because
people know that it's not a given that
all these promises at Christian saving
and the Supervisory Board Chairman are
making are going to be right in the end
and that everything is going to wind up
as they say but I think most people
agree that the costs are much too high
at the Deutsche Bank it has to do
something with the size of the staff
Investment Banking
a star in the past reaping tremendous
profits but a shadow of its former self
and also having all sorts of legal costs
that it brought to the bank and I think
most people think that this radical
approach is the right one coming very
late indeed though will he keep that
wasp at bay mr. bull cough I read a part
of yours this morning no sympathy for
the investment bankers losing their jobs
why I think well there's a lot of
sympathy for investors and beggars as
human beings but for sure they'll find a
job Investment Banking still alive and
kicking around the globe it's only not
for Deutsche because Deuter always has
been kind of outsider in this business
investment bank in London New York is
anglo-saxon style and okay they're both
investment bankers Anglo Saxon style
investment bankers but seemingly they
didn't buy the best one and these people
maybe haven't been very loyal they're
not the only ones going their way we've
got what one in five staff being thrown
out it sounds like there's something
systemically wrong with Deutsche and and
that would be management's fall not
their fault not the bank managers fought
for sure blots investment bankers fought
but I mean there's a fought for power
within the bank and they took over to
some degrees a bank and some was it
better to Bank lost its old strength as
a reliable partner to big companies in
Germany and this loss is really big and
now they try to regain this position it
will take a lot of time a lot of
persuasion to get back in this position
but it's very valuable because German
economy is thriving it's a strong
economy a good bank could live on that
only will that be enough though will
Deutsche Bank stick around
I think Deutsche Bank will stick around
will it stick around under its own
independent leadership that depends on
the success of this radical of
restructuring it's always possible and
some people think that an indeed is
likely that at some point considering
the low share price and the financing
and the big balance sheet that it might
be taken over by someone but its role in
financing both private customers and
especially corporate customers like
Professor Bob
just pointed out yes it's lost some
ground there but it still is number one
in Germany it's needed for many
companies so that role I think Georgia
Bank will continue to play in what
corporate structure that we have to see
depends on this program just briefly mr.
bull cough and finally the the banks no
stranger to scandals that even lent
Donald Trump money when no one else
would actually one tweet I read this
morning was that if Trump repaid all the
loans he owes the lender it wouldn't
have to cut any jobs at all that's
absolutely wrong I mean Trump is not
that important the volume isn't that big
I think Deutsche Bank can do very well
without Trump it would be better off
without the loans to Trump but it's not
really relevant for business of Deutsche
Bank mr. Bowker thank you very much for
charming chiming in from Stuttgart and
Olli bats first in Frankfurt outside
Deutsche Bank headquarters